mientras Los mercenarios rusos del grupo
Wagner avanzaban hacia Moscú en las
calles de la capital de Rusia se
respiraba una mezcla de incertidumbre y
temor Me parece que nuestro ejército
podrá detenerlo bueno es algún tipo de
ambición cuando tienes mucha gente a tus
órdenes empiezas a sentir algún tipo de
poder Quizás por eso lo hizo
pensaba que la situación en general
podía ser peligrosa y que ocurriría algo
así era una suposición cuando todo
ocurrió había una atención interior en
rostov los paramilitares liderados por
Jeff Jenny frigoyin afirman haberse
tomado el cuartel general y descansan en
las calles junto a sus vehículos
blindados muchos les ofrecen comida y
agua otros esperan las acciones del
ejército del kremlin No creo que hayan
capturado la ciudad creo que se llevará
a cabo algún tipo de negociación y
nuestras autoridades tomarán todas las
medidas necesarias
Mientras tanto en algunos ciudadanos
esperan que el conflicto se traslade al
territorio ruso
Leo muchas noticias y rezo para que
realmente ocurra espero que sea el fin
de esta guerra y que sea el fin de
nuestra miseria y dolor
la rebelión de Los mercenarios de Wagner
podrían causar la invasión rusa a
Ucrania a favor de kiev en mitad de su
contraofensiva
si lo que está ocurriendo ahora en Rusia
cierto sólo nos beneficia a nosotros
cuanto antes termine esta guerra con
nuestra Victoria mejor para nosotros
todo el mundo está entusiasmado
Vladimir Putin calificó el levantamiento
como una traición a la patria pero
intenta evitar a toda Costa una guerra
civil en Rusia